all right guys one thing about me is I
have a sweet tooth and so I was craving
a lemon blueberry Loaf and this thing
was so soft so moist so decadent so good
let me tell you guys how to make it
first things first let's add our dry
ingredients to a bowl and give it a mix
and yes you can do this by hand I'm just
being using my stand mixer from
there you want to add your wet
ingredients and if you're wondering you
do not taste the sour cream it's just to
make it fluffy mix it for about five
minutes be sure not to over mix this is
the consistency you want next we're
gonna dust our blueberries with flour
just to ensure they don't stink to the
bottom during bacon then we're gonna
ever so gently just fold the mixture
again just to make sure everything's
Incorporated add it to a parchment lime
baking dish and bake and use a toothpick
to make sure the center is done while
that's bacon let's start on our sweet
and tangy glaze go ahead and give it a
nice mix from there pour it on top folks
you've got to try this one out